the opening of the NBA season is just
two weeks away but right now the focus
isn't on the games last Friday Houston
Rockets general manager Daryl Morey
posted this now-deleted tweet expressing
his support for protesters in Hong Kong
more a later apologised for the tweet
but it set off a firestorm in China and
then a counter-reaction here in the US
the flare-up is the subject of an
opinion piece published in The
Washington Post entitled the NBA thinks
it can ignore politics in China it's
wrong and we are joined by the author
and CBS n contributor Isaac stonefish
who has written two other articles on
this subject this week Isaac good
morning good morning
so you wrote in that Washington Post
article that in today's China the NBA is
a political organization expand on that
China today is such a political place
and the party which rules China tries to
hide that fact but the NBA in China
partners with the Ministry of Education
it has a training camp in the Chinese
region of Xinjiang where there's upwards
of a million Muslims in concentration
camps and so it legit amazes both the
parties rule and also the parties crimes
against humanity in Xinjiang and it does
this all at the same time pretending
that it's not political the NBA the NBA
is had a challenging time to say the
least
in responding to all of this where's the
latest in where they're at right now so
the NBA I think has done a nice job with
Commissioner silver statement which says
they stand up for free speech in China
but I think a lot of the damage has
already been done
it didn't make anybody happy it seemed
like right it's it's really hard to
thread the line between what the
Communist Party and what some Chinese
citizens want and what Americans want
and this is this has been a really
really tough time for the NBA and Isak
it really comes down to dollar signs
millions of dollars have been lost you
said $0.10 which is a digital
platforming Network that works with the
NBA has a 1.5 billion dollar contract
with the the organization they do so
they are paying the NBA quite a huge sum
to stream its games in China they said
they were stepping away from that deal
and now be
the NBA is still in political hot water
wouldn't be surprised if $0.10 tries to
say remember that deal these numbers
need to be a little bit lower it's a
really good time for them and not really
the issue is whether or not people in
the US American citizens have a right to
their freedom of speech in this country
right that's such a great point and I
think the way Beijing sees it is that
questions about Hong Kong is something
that it should decide and it should
police the way that Americans speak and
because the NBA does so much business in
China they don't really know how to come
down on that issue not a whole lot of
shoes in Washington right right now are
uniting both Republicans and Democrats
this one is certainly I think for a lot
of Republicans because they don't want
to attack Trump on Russia they don't
want to wade into that whole thing they
feel like they can be stronger and
tougher on the China issue Democrats
also feel like this is an area that they
can speak out on and yeah I mean it's I
guess nice bipartisan all right Isaac
stone if you weren't paying attention to
what's going on in Hong Kong as a sports
fan perhaps you are now thank you